it's spider warren time we're gonna
watch today from cosmic spider-man
no way home real plot leak leak teaser
with trailer release date
speaking of trailer i want to give you
guys a heads up start editing
a little opening sketch for whenever the
heck
that spider-man no way home trailer
finally comes out and while it's not the
craziest
thing we've ever put together it's a
little bit of an ambitious edit yeah we
specifically designed this one
just for the fans of the real rejects
you know if you're if you haven't been
watching our spiderman coverage up until
then you might be like
what is this if you actually watch our
coverage of many uh
many a thing i don't want to give away
too much you'll know why i'm saying all
this it's for like
like the guys who are clicking on this
video right now who are liking these
videos trust me you'll you'll get a kick
out of it that's all i'll say let's
watch this video
[Music]
it looks like sony sony japan that is
might have pulled a whoopsie this
morning by releasing this on
accident it's a mini teaser trailer of
the actual teaser trailer it simply
tells
us when the release date is going to be
however it is unconfirmed right now if
this
is indeed probably this is going around
everywhere
online right now and if this is true
then well we only have three days to
wait until we get the official
spider-man no way home teaser now i
found out
a little bit of spider-man no way home
teaser trailer information that i'll
share
some of in this video and i also have
found out that there are actually some
plot links out there that
are very very that's what we're here for
discussing
in this video so if you love spider-man
from one of those today on
be sure to subscribe now i'm gonna go
ahead and say that this leak
is probably fake even if the trailer
does come out on july 22nd i still
believe that this particular video
isn't real my main thinking behind this
is that there's a really weird
spider-man in the beginning that seems
to be edited in
and his shoulders just covering the
release date which apparently is july
22nd
and two it's a little too convenient
that his shoulder
is barely covering the release date if
sony japan
or sony in general were going to put out
a teaser for a teaser they would
actually give us the date they wouldn't
just show part of it and that's really
my main reasoning for thinking that this
is probably not too legitimate you fake
trailer people are getting really good
but yeah i think that's definitely a
fake
i love how you saved yourself warren two
but if it is comes out it's still fake
yeah yeah well you know i mean it's a
smart way to save face in case
it's just the spider-man graph it's like
i feel like they even could have done it
that's the one part that doesn't look
quite big yeah
yeah yeah good call on specifically that
one too so i checked with both of my
sources
they haven't heard anything yet but what
i have heard and seen online from
legitimate sources and people
is that the trailer is expected to come
out between now and the release of
marvel's what if on disney class you're
gonna say the release of the
film it's about the 20-day window in
which the spider-man trailer could come
out right now
it's been 20 days for two years and
right now that's
really all that we've heard
unfortunately i do think that this is
fake but of course there's always the
possibility that it could be real and
yes spiderman no way home is the worst
kept secret in hollywood right now but
i'm not sure if
sony japan or anybody else from sony is
dropping
teasers about the teaser if they are
what an interesting tactic
and i mean hey it's gonna work but we'll
have to wait and see on that they do
that with us
like i said i have heard things about
some specific plot leaks out there
and one of them out there is very
legitimate and of course i'm going to go
over it and i've actually gone over it
before this was before
i had any confirmation that it was
indeed real and typically with plot
leaks there's always typically
something that is true about it we've
learned since avengers infinity war and
avengers in-game and the rest of the
movies and shows that have come out
typically with plot leaks there are
aspects of each plot leak that is real
however spider-man's definitely in this
pretty much all of it is legitimate and
i've even seen some people online like
grace randolph stating that
there is a 100 percent real plot leak
out there online right now and i believe
it's this one she was right about the
mandalorian
this entire time so it won't be that big
of a surprise but it sure
is exciting so let's go again i've
talked about this one before but
let's talk about it like this is
actually what is going to happen
it starts off by saying peter's life is
ruined
after his identity was revealed at the
end of the last spider-man movie
spider-man no way home he's now facing
trial and
matt murdock is his lawyer peter goes to
doctor strange
and asks him to cast a spell to make
everyone forget that he
is spider-man doctor strange actually
agrees to this but
something goes wrong with the spell and
they break reality and bring
five spider-man villains of other
dimensions into the marvel
cinematic universe the green goblin from
spider-man 1
doc ock from spider-man 2 the sandman
from spider-man 3
lizard from the amazing spider-man and
electro from the amazing spider-man 2.
norman osborne is talking to the others
asking what is the last thing that they
remember
and they all say that spider-man killed
them that's the last thing they remember
dying at the hands of spider-man and
this is what each of them
individually say doctor strange wants to
take them back to their original
dimensions
but the villains fear that returning
would mean that they would return
exactly where they came from
meaning they would die again at the
hands of spider-man
okay so the idea is that they all appear
at once it's not like you they this
person gets a scene
and then this person gets a scene like a
reintroduction then a reinstruction
they're all just going to kind of come
in
like this ensemble of a villain's
introduction if you're going to fit this
in a two and a half hour movie i feel
like
maybe you have to do it that way yeah or
or make it a montage where they all
link up pretty quick afterwards or
something but it does seem like
they enter a captivity right away yeah
that's what it sounds like maybe
somebody's taking advantage of the
multiverse to like triangulate them all
into the same
place or something like that and like
damn strange
you got messed up you tried doing one
spell and you end up doing something
that's the complete opposite i mean you
just get the ultimate reminders of
spider-man
i guess yeah i mean maybe that's sure
i'll help you forget i'll everyone
forget
here's the biggest reminder of every
spider-man
well that's that's the thing is that
they're always just going to show up
like right in the sanctum santorum or
something like that then and
this really sounds like it's heaping up
to be dr strange's fault
dr strange is keeping all of these
villains trapped in a magical prison
and peter doesn't really feel right
about that so norman osborn aka the
green goblin manipulates peter into
freeing them
making him feel guilty for their deaths
this leads to a major conflict between
doctor strange and peter parker
so peter fights doctor strange and
breaks the key which is a cube
that held them captive in the prison and
the villains are now
free they start destroying parts of new
york and to stop them
peter somehow brings toby maguire
spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man into the marvel cinematic
universe they just want an apology
the final battle is going to be at the
statue of liberty with the three
spider-mans fighting together
fighting the sinister six and the person
who provided this plot leak said to be
clear i have
no idea who the sixth member is or when
and how
he comes to the scene and that very well
could mean that it's going to be a
villain from our own universe
since all of these other characters are
indeed multiversal villains it would
make sense to have at least
one villain from our own universe heck
maybe even mysterio is alive which is
something that i
kind of believe and hope for and i
wouldn't put it past the master of
illusions mysterio to still be alive his
whole death
being a grand illusion let's play some
bets right now
all right vulture or mysterio i would
i would say vulture would be a decent
bet i would say so cause we've already
also seen him show back up as adrian
tombs in that mobius
trailer like morbius that's a pretty
likely
choice plus everyone loves michael
keaton there's a miniature keaton
science going on here
to conquer yeah jonathan matrix just
another kang variant yeah
perfect yeah let's just keep introducing
kang until we get to the conqueror very
yeah every upcoming marvel project but
mysterio also seems like a
i would like it if it is mysterio
because that would be the ultimate i
think it should be both versions of
shocker you know what you can do is you
could have
logan marshall green play the first
shocker yeah but then when shocker gets
his mask
then you put the black guy then you put
boheme woodbine that way you just piss
off however
union we were to make it two different
jokes you're making a devil this is a
multiverse joke i'm making a joke about
it would piss people off that once he
gets a mask that's when you put a black
guy in there
yeah absolutely that's a better joke
because that's got social commentary
which is what these movies are aiming
now let's talk about some key parts to
this one key part is
actually something that we've been
hearing for a very long time
it was reported on well over a year ago
that spider-man
looks like a werewolf there because he
doesn't want to usually be responsible
for releasing the villains
now at first that was really all of the
context that we were given just that
spider-man releases the villains we
didn't really know what that meant
though
however now we do doctor strange
actually puts them in a magical prison
then peter parker releases them that's
how it happens
now as far as the villains actually
coming into our reality
loki kind of explains how this could
happen the multiverse is now
a thing there are tons and tons of
branch alternate timelines and there
weren't before
there was just one sacred timeline and
perhaps doctor strange although i would
find it very odd if he didn't know but
perhaps he doesn't know
about all of these alternate branches
yet because that could be happening at
the exact same time he's dealing with
peter parker so he casts a spell that
before
probably wouldn't have been that big of
a deal but now since there are multiple
timelines and branches it is a big deal
and it does
actually affect the multiverse and this
could be how they come in doctor strange
isn't aware that another timeline is so
close to theirs so the spell ends up
bringing other variants into the mcu
and from here something else that is in
this plot like that has been talked
about for a while
is that peter parker and doctor strange
aren't going to agree on something
well we now know what that is it's the
fact that doctor strange is holding
these villains in a prison cell and
wants to send them back to their
original timelines
now of course this would in turn kill
them because that's what was going to
happen to them before
spider-man killing them so our peter
parker being a spider-man variant
feels guilty about this and somewhat
responsible since they are dying to a
spider-man even though it's not him
so this is clearly their disagreement
doctor strange thinks they should be
sent back
even if it's going to kill them and
peter parker disagrees whatever peter's
solution could have been
on how to save them who knows that's got
to be some far-fetched lie like i could
see goblin thinking that yeah peter was
going to kill me but like doc
hawk like selflessly sacrifices like to
save everybody from his own madness
to be honest i don't really remember
elektra's final moments
they were good they're talking about
sandman returning same thing yeah
they're talking about lizard return
elizabeth's confirmed return i believe
even he has kind of a change of heart
attack yeah exactly
they all kind of got to be human
characters so
it's got to be some lie that they're all
suddenly saying it seems kind of
odd to me again with unless you never
know
what excess multiversal mumbo jumbo will
help them
out but it does feel like these are
still several different
minded villains very different
motivations
they all could be variants from the
movies that were watching too though
yeah one that's another thing i've been
wondering because they've at least
confirmed i think at one point like
jamie foxx he's not going to be the same
blue character from before i guess at
least some of them
have to be different variants and not
like the same exact ones
yeah maybe just his experience was much
harsher he ends up breaking them
out and they end up causing havoc on new
york and the final scene is on the
statue of liberty which we actually know
this to be real as well
we've actually seen leaked photos of the
statue of liberty on the spider-man set
and we've actually seen the statue of
liberty holding a captain
america shield so who knows what's
happening there but exciting nonetheless
so be sure to let me know what you think
about this plot leak as i've been told
that it is
pretty much legitimate this is probably
what we're going to be seeing in
spider-man no way home so
let me know your thoughts on this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and of course for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof i already follow you suddenly
to do anything you just said boom that's
that's that's
you're you're winning love you warren
great job buddy
killing it can't wait to see what you
get right and what you get
freaking wrong when that movie actually
comes out
with all these leaks that you came up
with yeah
your fan fiction i think the phase four
theme truly just is like
all the marvel core characters messing
up and having to deal with that
hell yeah cause i love how half these
spider-man lakes are like doctor strange
screwed this spell up and then peter
made a bad choice about the villains
well guys what do you think about spidey
letting all them go
does that bode welfare did that sound
like a peter choice
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button last but not least
jason the dolan if there's anyone
here at our patreon who has been just
like
an uncle ben to the both of us jason
actually
said he was in town and
i'm not supposed to tell you
uncle no continue it can still work
because uncle ben
is no longer in peter's life and now i
feel a lot like peter
because you know here i am thinking like
oh jason we're close we're buds and now
i find out
you know you're here in spirit for for
me one thing he also mentioned was he
really
hates the uncle ben character
so you're happy hogan now and we're in
the mcu
and broken a really nasty dispute
have you seen the italian spider-man
youtube video
he's a big fan of that you are that
italian spider-man truly
to me all right we did the shout out
good jason
you're awesome cazzy reacts go go watch
her stuff
she's the real aunt may
[Music]